Hey whats up everyone *Clap Clap*
ITS MEME REVIEW TIME (i'm done )
and you know what that means
Time for some below-average entertainment.
but FIRST
buh buh buh buh!
i forgot contact lenses!
And now I look like my Papii!
*puts sunglasses*
that's better
clap
CLAP
NEXT MEME
Let's get a really good meme in here.
let's get a really good one
video: Hamburger
(im not typing all this out jfc)
*dying inside intensifies*
Hamburger.
hamburger is a meme now everyone.
It finally happened congratulations to everyone that invested in the hammburger stock market.
It's finally payoff time
Cuz Hamburger Is A Meme.
HAMBURGER.
steve: I'm going to Mcdonald's
do you want a Hamburger
scott:Hamburger
HHAAMMBBUUR-
That relatable moment where you're part of the Avengers
and Thor asks "I'm going to Mcdonald's u want a hamburger?"
Smash like if you can relate to this video.
right fricking now
what flavor you asked?
HAMBURGER
this originated from youtube poop?
who had sonic saying hamburger
Thank you youtube poop
HAMBURGER
My God
Will this reference be seen in the sonic film? It remains to be seen
Good sentence Felix
Thank you
HAMBURGER
Why is everyone saying hamburger?
Has everyone just frickin lost their mind?
What is frick is happening?
Millennial humor is so weird
[It's those Gen-Z kids tho]
Yoda: What if you
wanted to go to heaven
but God said
h a m b u r g e r
I think this is another existential question
that we've all asked ourselves at one point or another
I mean what would you do,
literally what would you do
I don't know what I would do
I would just say hamburgers as well probably
and hope for the best
hamburgers
Is that a hamburger?
That is a hamburger!
Oh
Woah
w o a h
H A M B U R G E R
hehehe hamburger
He said it
Yayy :)
haammmBUUURRGG E E R R R R
hamburger
What has happened
We used to have Ugandan Knuckles, god damn it
Why the frick is hamburger a meme
It's not even that funny of a food
I can name at least five other
funny foods at the top of my head
ʰᵃᵐᵇᵘʳᵍᵉʳ
I can name at least five other
funny foods at the top of my head
Chicken tequila masala
What the frick kind of name is that
shootbyooler [idk]
Oh wow, sounds way funnier
I love hamburger
Say it Yoda
Oh my god, who's gonna say it
HAM-
it's African
I'm South African
I have no accent though cuz I was raised here
ḧ̵̡̫͙͈͕͓̐̂͑̉̋̿͗͐͒̔͘̕͘ͅa̴̛̛͖̳̯̻̥̤̱̻͑̽̂̇̐̈́̎̂̃̿͒͑͜͠m̵̧̢͕͂̍̀̾͛̾̄̍b̸̢̪̗̰̖̤̳̞̃̐̄̄́̈́̇̕̕ṵ̷͙̪̠̳̦͚̩̤́̽͆̔̎̌̍͘ͅŗ̴̥̻̦̝͓̖͔̟͚̻͚̆̏g̴̯͙̬̜̩̮̯̙̤̯͈̯̺̝̞̋̌e̵̠̦̹͕̫̯̦͚̊̑̽́̀̒r̸̘̘̥̪͍̩̮͚̰͔̳̽̍̇̇̽̀͑́̉̿̿̚
These compilations
completely ruin the joke
because you know exactly what they're gonna say
At least if you're scrolling through Instagram or whatever
you don't know exactly what meme it's gonna be
But you wa- you sit through a compilation and it's like
I'm just waiting for them to say hamburger
*exciting music*
hamburger hamburger ham-
You know if it didn't say hamburger,
then I would laugh all right?
You need to surprise me at least
Goddamnit Felix, why are you so salty now, huh?
Why are you being such a ḧ̵̡̫͙͈͕͓̐̂͑̉̋̿͗͐͒̔͘̕͘ͅa̴̛̛͖̳̯̻̥̤̱̻͑̽̂̇̐̈́̎̂̃̿͒͑͜͠m̵̧̢͕͂̍̀̾͛̾̄̍b̸̢̪̗̰̖̤̳̞̃̐̄̄́̈́̇̕̕ṵ̷͙̪̠̳̦͚̩̤́̽͆̔̎̌̍͘ͅŗ̴̥̻̦̝͓̖͔̟͚̻͚̆̏g̴̯͙̬̜̩̮̯̙̤̯͈̯̺̝̞̋̌e̵̠̦̹͕̫̯̦͚̊̑̽́̀̒r̸̘̘̥̪͍̩̮͚̰͔̳̽̍̇̇̽̀͑́̉̿̿̚?
Because I want to goddamn it
and you can't stop me
"Captain!!!"
"Yeah, yeah?"
Look...
Hamburger.
You see what I mean?
You know enough of this
I'll show you some good memes
*reads meme*
Now that's funny
Come on
Oh you oh I'm sorry you want more hamburger compilation memes?
Sorry alright sure
[no I really don't]
I'll give you a hamburger compilation
HAMBURGER!!!
*screaming* Hamburger hamburger
Okay that one was good I did like that one
Sorry hamburger, I take everything back
You're so funny
I love you so much
Like this, this is a funny meme!
He's holding it with his ass cheek!
He's dummy thick
Alright guys, serious question time
No more jokes
No more playing around
Serious question time okay?
You ready to answer question you
have three seconds to answer
Alright, you get either 500 euro
but you have to delete your Facebook account forever
Absolute win!
I'll take it, easy!
Next one, okay okay
I realize that one was a little bit easy
How about this one
You are very attractive to the opposite sex
But!
You are also very attractive to the same sex
and your skin is green
*gentle piano*
*sweeping violins*
*CHOKING NOISES*
Food for thought
Okay, all right, I realize
These are a little bit easy questions
I got a better one for you coming right up
You only get two seconds to answer this one
You DIE
All right?
BUT
B U T
Fortnite dies too
Goddamn this is so easy
Just kill me
You have one second to answer this one
all right?
Instagram DIES
BUT
Reddit is always in light mode
No freaking dude look [wat]
My eyes will die
These are so sh-
Can I get one funny meme this week
Jesus Christ
All right here we go
~Bowling alley memes~
You heard about these?
You've heard about bowling alley
memes?
Remember you were bowling as a kid
and the animation what we may more fun
than the actual game
*reads meme*
Now this is a good meme
Thank you Lord thank the Lord Almighty
*reads meme*
Legit I would have more fun looking at the goddamn screen than playing bowling
Who likes bowling anyway [I think it's alright]
Alright let's get another good meme in
here
*reads tweet*
*unintelligable screaming*
You think you're thunny [funny]
with your little jokes?
You're not funny
You're gay [maybe like happy]
and I mean that in the best way possible
Brofist if you're gay too
*reads meme*
I kinda- I don't know about you guys,
but I kinda wanna go bowling now
I kind of bowling
Yes, that's it!
Smash like if this is completely freaking accurate
*reads meme*
Who made these, that's a good point actually
If you're a bowling alley 3d model design creator,
hit me up in the comments with the likes
just so I know if you're there
*reads meme*
That relatable moment
Even this joke
The novelty wears off pretty quickly, doesn't it
*reads meme*
♪ Sweet dreams are made of these ♪
♪ Who am I ♪
♪ to piss on me ♪
I changed the lyrics just so they can't copy strike it
It's fine
It's called innovation
Learn what it is
UMG [idk what this means]
*reads meme*
Wait wait wait
Click loop
and then play, there it is
This is humor all right? You stupid Millennials [stahp]
You stinky Millennials [I feel attacked]
with your silly dummy dumb humor
[maybe I won't sub your videos anymore]
This is humor, all right?
I don't care about obscure h a m b u r g e r
All right, what do we got
Daaaaaamn
Alright do we get to see the strike?
There it is :D
♪ *singing something *♪
That's it.
Ten out of ten
Bowl play bowling [what]
never again
lightskinnedmonte posted this clip
on Instagram
OH
A RAT!
There's a rat
Mother f-ing rat
Hood N-words when they see a rat
I think we can all relate
Ohhhh
what's he gonna do now
I take everything
back
goddamnit oh damn eight oh no no stop
hamburgers stop the goddamn hamburgers
and we want to see another hamburger
meaning my goddamn lie okay oh hey is it
gonna mine it it's gonna dare ahead hey
come on some of these are good I'll have
it to you guys your little editors with
your little Andes
you think you're so good Oh a very sexy
man that Ricardo okay that's good
absolute win this has been the last meme
review ever I sorry I forgot to tell you
guys but it's over I'm Mary ham and I'm
just canceling all the shows I'm sick of
it I want none of it anymore and I see
you never again spying what you never
played super simulator you know it's fun
right I'm not supposed to give my
opinion but give it a try and then you
can tell me if it's good or not not
convinced yet okay I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price